we continue our team coverage now at
sunrise hospital and medical center a
big day for them
they partnered with the u.s department
of health and human services
to operate an infusion clinic to treat
cobit 19 patients
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joining us now live from sunrise to
explain
madison yes the antibody infusion clinic
here at sunrise is definitely something
special as it is the third to open
in the country
the goal of this clinic is to treat
covet 19 patients who are at high risk
of being hospitalized due to the virus
now for clarification monoclonal
antibodies are laboratory-made proteins
that resemble the immune system's
ability
to fight up harmful viruses like covet
19.
we have a standalone clinic that we have
eight treatment chairs eight infusion
chairs
for patients will be able to care for 32
patients per day
and those patients need to be referred
from other emergency rooms
physician offices urgent care centers
the hope is that through this clinic
coveted patients can get treated without
going to a hospital not only saving the
patient's life but keeping hospitals
from getting overcrowded
the process takes two to two and a half
hours we're able to reduce
through the use of this therapy seventy
percent
reduction in patients that potentially
could be admitted
for those who are eligible to receive
the antibodies
meaning once they receive their
antibodies the
rate of hospitalization decreases
from 15 percent to 4 percent at sunrise
hospital they're currently at an
all-time
high with more than 200 covet patients
they expect those numbers to increase
due to the holidays
and now this should be known that this
is for high risk adults only so we're
talking about adults that may have
heart disease diabetes have problems
with hypertension or are 65 and older
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now